I heard you like really get a major
thing for robbing yes yeah I do I
actually I actually wrote her a poem
that's the greatest when did you start
I've suppressed them I I've always you
know whatever I watched your movie a
million times ever since that movie I
suppress my feelings about Robin yeah
but not just how you look but your
personality and you know and how we're
begging you to come back I love that
once I got a divorce I realized wow I
you know what maybe I
yeah and I've actually dated a black
woman since you have yeah but she's not
Robin she's not Robin no no nobody's
robbing nobody is wrong I guess well you
know she's gotten a diary single right
she broke up recently Robin are you
interested in Kurt I know you're a
wrestling fan I mean by the way and I'm
gonna say this and I know it doesn't
embarrass Robert cuz we spoke about how
she's been with a guy who had 11 are you
gonna be able to compete you're not
close to a lot inches Robin I'm sorry
I'll do whatever I have to do I mean if
I have to use extra stuff and do you
actually talk about that my pollen tube
are you it should Kurt waste his time
with the poem or she's flustered yes I
got that Robin very sweet alright this
is Kurt I haven't even done this when I
proposed to my wife and never got on my
knees actually she proposed to me so
[Laughter]
here we go
to my love Robin I am a bachelor and
true love is hard to find I may be a
wrestler but you may love me for my mind
you are living the single life again and
are ready for the next phase and just
like dr. Ronnie I will make you a new
woman in just 21 days I want to go
meddling in the Olympics they say I've
never been beat I am also a gold
medalist in the sack much better than
vegetables and me DNA pays me millions
to wrestle and cross the line I will
never ever [ __ ] even about an $800
bottle of wine we can go to the theater
we can roll around in the grass we can
have coffee at Starbucks just don't try
to squirt it up my ass
[Laughter]
Wow
Robin please give me a chance for a love
like you've never seen and I am much
more well-hung than that damn jim
Florentine
I will look past your shortcomings and
unlike Howard I don't snore I don't even
care that you scored a [ __ ] 34 I
would care about any man who disrespects
you I will certainly strangle he's a
real man yeah is the big ending so how
does this sound my sweetheart Oh Robin
Oh philia angle
Wow Wow better I'm gonna answer for
Robin yes I can make love to you all
night and I'll make you squeal I'll have
you screaming it's real it's damn real
and the real Gabriel is my wrestling
phrase I don't want to lose the momentum
but Robin what do you say to this and
what do you say to a man who just got on
his knees yeah I am very impressed now
would you go out with Kurt Angle if he
asked you know how soon can you let him
in your pants so he can take you for a
test ride Oh God we have to coordinate
our schedules you know me I'm always
busy right yeah I am too Rob and I we
have that in common
would you guys mind going right now and
having sex in the greenroom and sniff
it's good and if it's good you clearly
stated your intentions maybe after the
show you God Robin all right well take
care of yourself
[Laughter]